[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur la bbc une surréaliste
et hopitalisé il était nulle part parce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de moi même toute
cette histoire est donc ça m'a apporté
un peu de recul un peu d'apaisement mais
la douleur et la colère seront là
jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mercredi 1er décembre
les restrictions qui se multiplient
partout dans le monde après l'apparition
du nouveau variant omicron la présidente
de la commission européenne appelle à
réfléchir à la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous la france elle n'envisage pas
pour l'instant cette mesure mais durcit
les conditions pour les voyageurs
non-européens alors la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous inévitable en
étant vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme verte et france pour
alimenter le débat autour de nous
inviter
les femmes françaises pourrait peut-être
avoir plus de temps pour avorter les
députés ont approuvé en tout cas
l'extension de douze à quatorze semaines
du délai légal pour liv et j'ai l'avenir
du droit à l'avortement aux états unis
ce jour lui ce soir devant la cour
suprême les neuf sages se penche sur une
loi adoptée en 2018 au mississippi qui
interdit les avortements après quinze
semaines de grossesse les explications
avec notre correspondant à washington
est notre invité en plateau
au sommaire dès 21h la lutte pour
l'égalité des genres au centre des
débats la proche de la présidentielle
jean-luc mélenchon en a fait l'un de ses
chevaux de bataille le candidat la
france insoumise veut même l'inscrire
dans la constitution ce droit de choisir
son gens mais va-t-il trop loin certains
en tout cas le pense dans notre repris
qu'en pensent les français nous irons à
la rencontre de marie qu'au premier mr
30 ans du pays et nous livrera son
témoignage et nous en débattrons avec à
nos invités
le variant omikron continue donc de
gagner du terrain dans le monde
plusieurs pays ont décidé de fermer
leurs frontières la france également
renforce les contrôles pour les arrivées
avec les contaminations qui repartent à
la hausse cinquante mille nouveaux cas
en 24 heures on en parle tout de suite
avec notre reporter estelle farges
devant l'elysée bonsoir estelle alors ça
y est la france qui durcit à partir
d'aujourd'hui donc les conditions
d'accès au territoire national
et oui stéphanie tous les voyageurs qui
souhaitent se rendre en france même ceux
qui sont vaccinées vont devoir présenter
un test pcr négatif de -2 48 heures pour
les voyageurs n'ont vacciné et en
provenance de l'union européenne
le délai est réduit à 24 heures des
mesures annoncées à par gabriela talent
ce matin à l'issue du conseil des
ministres et qui entreront en vigueur le
4 décembre prochain le porte parole du
gouvernement qui a aussi indiqué que les
vols avec à dix pays d'afrique australe
reprendront l samedi mais ils seront
strictement encadrés je propose de
l'écouter
s'agissant des pays de l'afrique
australe que j'évoquais à l'instant le
rétablissement des vols se fera bien à
compter de samedi mais il se fera avec
un encadrement extrêmement strictes et
drastiques vous connaissez la
classification des pays qui existent
aujourd'hui pour notre gestion il ya les
pays rouges les pays orange et les pays
vers nous créons une nouvelle catégorie
de pays rouges écarlates s'agissant des
pays les plus à risque notamment avec la
présence du variant omicron 7 que cette
catégorie rouge écarlate intégrera les
sept pays de l'afrique australe pour
lesquels les vols étaient suspendus
depuis vendredi dernier s'y ajouteront
trois pays le malawi la zambie et l'île
maurice seules les personnes qui sont de
nationalité française ressortissants
européens
les personnels diplomatiques et les
personnels navigants pourront rejoindre
la france depuis ces dix pays il n'y
aura pas de déplacement ou d'accès à
autoriser à des fins professionnelles
touristique familiale d'études ou même
de recherche
sur le front à de la vaccination à
présent gabriela talent a annoncé la
réouverture de 300 centres de
vaccination avec la mise à disposition
de nouveaux créneaux et ce pour
désengorger
centre actuel comme l'a rappelé cet
après midi le ministre de la santé 18
millions deux français ont été appelés à
recevoir une dose de rappel les centres
de vaccination subissent donc je cite en
effet embouteillages normal olivier et
veyran qui s'est aussi exprimé sur la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
question actuellement sur la table au
sein de l'union européenne mais qui
n'est pas le choix de la france at il
assuré
le ministre de la santé qui a aussi
précisé qui dit obligation est dit
contrôle et sanction est donc la
faisabilité n'est pas évidente el farj
pour toutes ces précisions une
obligation vaccinale pour tous pas
encore envisagée par la france mais qui
semble gagner du terrain en europe
ursula von der leyen estime d'ailleurs
qu'une discussion devrait avoir lieu
soulignant qu'une telle décision
revenait évidemment aux états membres
est la mesure est déjà actée en autriche
l'allemagne pourtant longtemps opposé à
cette idée se pose désormais la question
mais ces vaccins obligatoires ou non
auront-ils une efficacité contre le
nouveau variant omicron qu'en est il de
la troisième d'audit de rappel éléments
de réponse avec emilie gogh h
réfléchir à la vaccination obligatoire
pour enrayer la flambée de l'épidémie
c'est la recommandation faite par la
présidente de la commission européenne
aux pays membres de l'ue et
je pense qu'il est compréhensible et
approprié d'avoir cette discussion
maintenant comment pouvons nous
encourager et potentiellement penser à
la vaccination obligatoire au sein de
l'union européenne cela doit être
discuté cela nécessite une approche
commune mais c'est une discussion qui je
pense doit être menée
la décision a elle déjà été prises par
l'autriche où une loi devrait imposer la
vaccination de la population adulte dès
le 1er février prochain
l'allemagne vient également d'annoncer
qu'une proposition de loi serait soumise
au parlement avant la fin de l'année en
attendant que l'obligation vaccinale se
concrétise ursula von der leyen assure
que tous les européens entièrement
vacciner pourront bientôt recevoir leur
troisième dose de rappel
nous aurons 360 millions de doses de
vaccins à arn messager qui seront livrés
d'ici la fin du premier trimestre 2010
22 c'est suffisant pour que tous les
européens complètement vaccinés
reçoivent une dose de rappel c'est une
bonne nouvelle alors allez-y boss
vaccination obligatoire troisième dose
mais les vaccins utilisés seront ils
efficaces contre le nouveau variant
omicron d'après l'agent ce médical de
l'union européenne il faudrait deux
semaines pour savoir si de nouveaux
vaccins sont nécessaires les faire
approuver prendrait alors trois à quatre
mois mais en attendant l'agencé estime
que la campagne de vaccination doit se
poursuivre
je pense qu'il est très important de
continuer à faire passer le message que
les vaccins actuels offrent une
protection et que nous devons nous
assurer que ceux qui sont éligibles pour
un rappel reçoivent les doses de rappel
en même temps nous devons nous préparer
au cas où il serait nécessaire de
modifier les vaccins actuels
une déclaration plutôt rassurantes
contrairement aux dernières mises en
garde de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé ce lundi l' oms a prévenu que les
caractéristiques de mikron pourrait lui
permettre d'échapper à la réponse
immunitaire notamment celle apportée par
la vaccination
alors on le rappelle l'obligation de se
faire vacciner c'est pour l'instant
réservée à certains à certaines
professions en france comme les
soignants les pompiers ou les
travailleurs au contact de personnes
âgées alors pour endiguer cette
cinquième vague qui fait peur faut-il
aller plus loin à la france devrait-elle
étendre l'obligation vaccinale à toute
la population on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le compte le télégramme
verte et france et c'est l'heure de
notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler j'accueille ce soir
sur ce plateau patrick mennucci bonsoir
patrick mennucci membres du ps ancien
député des bouches du rhône merci d'être
là à vos côtés en face gens là la
capelle député du rassemblement national
à bonsoir j'en ai à la capelle la
situation est pas terrible en cinquante
mille nouvelles continues mination en 24
heures plus de 32000 cas par jour en
moyenne sur les sept jours 13 car
officiel un patrick mennucci sur les
variants omikron il pourrait y en avoir
plus on en parle est un petit peu avant
7 cette émission la france quand même
qui sévit au niveau des frontières on
l'a entendu avec notre reporter ça va pu
être si évident de circuler entre
l'afrique australe et la france et
surtout désormais les voyageurs doivent
présenter des tests pcr négative de
moins de 48 heures avant leur entrée en
france y compris quand ils sont vaccinés
il était temps vous allez me dire
oui alors la halle alors l'heure
l'opération de communication aussi la
part du gouvernement moi je souhaite je
crois que c'est une bonne chose
d'essayer de réguler
nos frontières de manière à ce que la
propagation parce que c'est un mec des
frontières ne le supprime pas ne font
pas disparaître le virus en revanche ça
permet de freiner la propagation du
virus quand marine le pen au mois de
janvier rappelez-vous au début de la
crise et les terres avait recommandé la
fermeture des frontières elle avait été
accusée de tous les maux elle avait été
pointé du doigt et puis aujourd'hui on
sait bien ne compte que c'était quand
même un des vecteurs un des leviers pour
essayer de contrôler
cette la propagation de cette épidémie
donc je souhaite que le gouvernement
aille hommes de démo jusque jusqu en
effet la comptabilisation de 2,6
souhaite puisque j'ai été vous savez moi
il ya quelques il ya quelques semaines
en russie notamment au kazakhstan gm
était en déplacement parlementaire aux
états unis je suis revenu de ces
destinations la dans les aéroports
français sans aucun contrôle aucun
contrôle à l'entrée ce que le
gouvernement dit et parfois je joue et
je le reconnais sur notamment sa fermeté
sur les frontières dans les mots je lui
reconnais une butte aux une bonne
attention je voudrais simplement que
derrière ça puisse se concrétiser en
actes patrick mais aussi ce que dit jean
lannes à cap alors je me permets de dire
que ce n'est pas faux parce que qui a un
petit peu voyagé derniers temps se rend
compte qu'il faut faire un test de tests
pcr pour aller dans les pays que ce soit
maroc voilà plusieurs pays et là les
frontières sont fermées que le maroc
mais enfin avant et que c'est vrai qu'en
france on se contentait un petit peu
d'une déclaration sur l'honneur on a
fait preuve de laxisme ces dernières
semaines il faut changer ça justement
face à aux micros nous s'avouent
satisfaits du cas chez arte y a pas de
laxisme puisque on a été
tous les trois sourires et
voilà
moi moi je pense que oui que il ya deux
questions qui se posent il ya
la question de la vaccination des pays
émergents des pays pauvres c'est à dire
dans la vaccination mondiale en réalité
et la vaccination obligatoire des
européens et
en particulier les français c'est la
position du parti socialiste depuis
quelques mois puisque le groupe
socialiste vd une ppl exprimé cette
position à l'assemblée nationale c'est
la position de notre formation politique
ce que je crois qui est qui et qui est
important comme le député européen on va
pas aller critiquer le gouvernement
parce que il ya donc deux mesures qui
sont prises on comprend bien ce que
vient de dire le porte parle quand même
de permettre aux français qui seraient
pays d'afrique australe de rencontrer
aux seuls 2 et d'interdire les voyages
d'agrément les voyages professionnels
ça me frappe part est frappé au coin du
bon sens la question c'est que tout ça
ce sont des éléments
partiels et qui répondent à une
situation d'urgence il je pense qu'il
serait vraiment très important que le g7
où le g20
face à des actes hakem
internationaux très précis pour
s'assurer que les milliards d'individus
qui vivent cette planète est accès à la
vaccination parce que sinon
voit bien que les frontières sont quand
même
autant on peut parler de frontière quand
on parle de migration ou de contrôle
douanier que cela en matière de santé on
voit bien game que la difficulté extrême
en sommes et que on a l'a certainement
une physalie c'est-à-dire bloquer les
frontières limité c'est un épisode ce
qu'il faut c'est que tout le monde soit
vacciné et en attendant je crois que
vous avez dit vont parler mais je crois
que c'est très important même si ça pose
des questions de liberté même si ça pose
des questions
d'explication je crois qu'on devrait
obliger tous les français pour vacciner
on va justement rentrer dans ce débat
puisque c'est l'objet de votre présence
ce soir mais sur cette vaccination des
autres pays parce que c'était le gros
débat quand est apparu ce virus qu'on ne
connaît pas encore bien en afrique du
sud on n'a pas assez fait quand on voit
que la chine distribuer des milliards de
doses en afrique d ouvre des centres de
vaccination un coup nous voilà avec
kovacs c'est vrai que le rendement est
un peu plus modeste vous ça vous inspire
quoi en tant que député aussi justement
vous pousser pour convaincre davantage
en afrique et qu'on arrête ainsi les
peut-être davantage les virus sur le
principe du cea et et de s'impliquer
bien avant donc c'est une situation il
ya un souci mais à condition aussi comme
on est suffisamment de doses en assumant
des doses aussi pouvoir vacciner les
européens qui souhaitent être vaccinés
parce que propre à l'orangé bien compris
de l'obligation vaccinale et j'y suis
tout à fait opposé de nous y opposer mes
parents je je je je je
rappel quand même qu'au début de cette
crise sanitaire au moment au début
justement où le vaccin était né que nous
avons été quand même et je repère les
derniers à vraiment avoir les
approvisionner du vaccin nous avons été
un peu la risée du monde nous aimions
européenne pensantes de serions
meilleurs que les autres et pensons que
la clé d'entrée de cette négociation
d'ailleurs parlement européen devait
être le prix alors que quand vous êtes
en guerre c'est pas le prix ce qu'il
faut c'est être approvisionné le plus
possible et pouvoir ensuite mettre à
l'exposition des gens qui souhaitent
être vaccinés le vaccin et nous avons
pris les choses en main vers son arrêt
c'est d'acheter le moins cher en effet
d'acheter moins cher mais finalement
tout nous est passé devant donc dans la
commune erreur je crois de taki avec des
gens qui d'ailleurs passent leur temps à
négocier de manière extrêmement
déséquilibrée et qui ne défendent pas
les intérêts des européens voilà
maintenant concernant cette obligation
vaccinale nous sommes nous opposer à
l'aube et sociales sont pour la liberté
vaccinale nous sommes pour le principe
de consentement libre et éclairé mais en
france très sincèrement quand on voit le
pass asnières l'application de base
sanitaire globale son ex et elle est en
place de fait de fait puisque
aujourd'hui si vous voulez au restaurant
si vous voulez prendre le train si vous
voulez
aller au cinéma il vous faut un pass
anitea port se passe à lithaire il vous
faut finalement être vaccinés puisque si
vous souhaitez ne peuvent être vaccinés
on l'était ce vous l'avez compris la
gratuité viallet décider sur les tests
au fait ya quelques semaines la
réduction du délai de validité des tests
a été réduite à 24 heures tout cela pour
pousser les gens à être vaccinés donc en
fait le pas salutaire c'est une double
ication vaccinale déguisés et
qu'aujourd'hui si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné vous avez droit à la mort
sociale c'est ce que lula longues robes
aux pacers sanitaire vaccination
obligatoire qui dit pas son nom et et ça
suffit finalement je pense pas mais j'ai
de désaccord avec eux aussi la capelle
d'abord je pense que la vaccination au
mondial colombien john loin les les
théories évidemment du front national du
rassemblement national
vaccine on nous d'abord et puis s'il en
reste pour les autres je je je je pense
qu'il dit je pense qu dire que la
vaccination
c'est un principe de solidarité
extérieur non je ne crois pas je n'y a
pas de solidarité la danse à faire s'est
même pas des bons sentiments je pense
que la vaccination mondiale c'est un
principe de survie pour chacun d'entre
nous donc il faut il faut retourner la
question n'est pas là pour dire au mas
vacciner d'abord en suisse qui se passe
quelle suite au maximum les autres jeux
non nous on appelle à une grande prise
de conscience mondiale
toute offre toutefois évidemment je
pense à eux les autres ici d'un studio
et ailleurs
le fait que c'est pas nous qui allons
décider que nous nous adressons là au
grand pays aux grands dirigeants de ce
monde je parle du g20 mais qui me semble
qu'ils aiment plan international de
vaccination généralisée qui doit être
mis en oeuvre depuis la deuxième chose
pour parler en attendant cette affaire
la vienne vienne
je vois pas comment le pourraient pas
venir sinon ça va durer et et ça va
finir par poser de nombreux problèmes
sur les vaccins obligatoires moi je me
donne
la question de la conviction j'ai
discuté avec anne hidalgo y ait
effectivement pour se caler sur ces
sujets regardez soleil un joli nom et ma
liberté de choisir de me faire vacciner
ou non obligations obligations au nom de
quoi mais je vais vous expliquer au nom
de quoi
oui je crois que c'est très important
parce que c'est donc pas n débat
philosophique est d'une autre nature en
faut mais qui s'appuie sur une nécessité
sanitaire et jeudi johan hidalgo me
disait effectivement moi j'ai eu pas pas
favorable ça m'ennuierait d'être obligé
de le faire mais après koné fille
justement est-ce que vous expliquer
toutes ses obligations de limitation de
délais de ba et canetons bois qui a
encore une dizaine de millions de jeunes
qui sont bas les vaccinés on est bien
obligé de me passer par oublier assez
joué juste rappeler que vous vous même
de murs rue et moi nous sommes obligés
d'avoir trois vaccins la moment que nous
parlons et nos enfants j'ai regardé le
carnet de santé de mon fils
avec cette affaire-là c'est aux vaccins
donc la question de la vaccination
obligatoire n'est pas une question qui
est inconnu d'un spi - pour l'instant je
connaissais ceux qui étaient opposés
c'était et témoins de jéhovah chez pas
que le rassemblement national étaient
témoins de jéhovah je veux dire c'est
eux et qui d'ailleurs ne s'est pas sur
une question de liberté c'est sur une
question éthique philosophique
religieuse pas votre cas donc moi je
pense que les grandes formations
politiques de ce pays où il joue mais
deux dames devrait être absolument dans
une visio mais s'adresser aux français
pour dire oui ça doit pas être un débat
politique c'est une nécessité que tous
nos concitoyens sur vacciner je pense
qu'il faut il faut y aller je regrette
qu aux policiers ne soit pas celle là
jean lannes incapable je vais vous lève
c'est évidemment répondre mais je
voudrais vous faire quand même égouttez
aussi françois bayrou qui défend
également comme vous patrick mennucci la
vaccination obligatoire écouter
le jour viendra où la vaccination
obligatoire s'imposera je dis ça depuis
le mois de janvier à l'époque on
craignait que le vaccin n'est des effets
secondaires
des gens qui disaient ça va être une
hécatombe or on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
que c'est absolument faux votre café
mais il ya des vaccins en effet vous
l'avez dit qu'ils sont la clé donc
aujourd'hui une obligation mais en a 40
ans de recul le bcg la polio l'hépatite
donc ce sont des vaccins qui sont connus
reconnus
expérimentés et on a été au bout des
protocoles
d'expérimentation et on sait ce qu'ils
sont et les et les effets secondaires
peuvent produire ce vaccin là on n'a pas
de recul il est développé de manière
extraordinairement rapide et très bien
bravo aux chercheurs mais on n'a pas
assez drôle justement
dit le contraire c'est que voilà il dit
on a suffisamment de recul on s'aperçoit
que c'est monsieur bayrou et moraux et
politiques que moi d'ailleurs moi je me
permets pas de parler à la base d'un
simple mot scientifique qui eux disent
qu'on n'a pas le recul que l'on avait
sur celui de la polio du bcg quand on
les a rendus histoire et quand j'entends
madame von der leyen aujourd'hui
président de la commission européenne
qui en effet dit je suis pour la
vaccination obligatoire au niveau
européen toute contente tout content
d'avoir eu un de ses contacts c'est
probablement le pdg de pfizer au
téléphone en dix ans et je vous annonce
une très bonne nouvelle aussi le vaccin
pour les enfants est prêt mais je me
demande d'ailleurs si après les intérêts
économiques derrière parce que ce
rapport direct entre les politiques et
les patrons les présidents de
laboratoire me dérange toujours et
suscite chez point d'interrogation mais
d'autres pas mais où va-t-on on va créer
en fait ddd des citoyens ou des
compatriotes à deux vitesses parce qu'on
se rend compte aujourd'hui que être
vaccinés
aujourd'hui doublement vacciner
suffisamment par abord quelqu'un qui a
un test négatif qui est-ce qui peut
contaminer le plus entre jean castex qui
est double watier qui va continuer 12
personnes quelqu un qu un test négatif
comme nous à l'instant qui aujourd'hui
le plus dangereux mais c'est havrais
c'était une occasion aujourd'hui
évidemment ce vaccin dont nous avait dit
qu'il il empêcherait la transmission ou
la réception du virus ne tient pas ses
promesses donc c'est un vrai problème et
deuxièmement je termine quand je prends
les exemples comme en europe comme
lettonie qui
interdit le droit de vote aux
parlementaires sont pas vaccinés contre
l'autriche a voulu confiné
les non vaccinés et cordes enfin en
hollande ils ont tiré à balles réelles
maintenant ça ne m'est veste en on va
tirer donc écouter ou est-ce qu'on va
mais où est ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on
voit dans un monde à deux vitesses où il
ya et je crois que la pandémie avant lui
daniel segonds de politique un petit peu
de recul et notamment sur nos enfants
car je suis absolument totalement
opposées vraiment à la vaccination des
enfants parce qu'il n'y a aucun recul 0
gonds la même pas les deux années de
cette pandémie on en a pas et c'est pas
normal qu'aujourd'hui
madame von der leyen par exemple et
d'autres politiques en france se
permette de sponsoriser ce type de
discours parce que je crois qu'ils
mettent en danger l'avenir nos avants
patrick mennucci je voulais vous faire
écouter vanger leyen mais vous avez un
peu tout dit aujourd'hui van der leyen
qui dit on devrait commencer à y penser
au sein de l'europe même si les états
restent souvent c'est vrai que j'en à la
capelle l'adie l'autriche y est mise
l'allemagne se pose la question est ce
que on ne va pas y couper en france je
pense qu'on va y arriver moi ce que je
nous ai fait des contre la trahison
envers les citoyens
le président nation non mais peut-être
que le président ne fera jamais mais
c'est une erreur jeudi dans le jeu le
président il faut il regarde juste ses
intérêts
ddd - qui vient de peut-il d'ailleurs
opposé au jeune sais rien mais ce que
j'entends c'est quand même que beaucoup
de ses amis
ils sont favorables mais en même temps
monsieur bo et surtout moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que je pense qu'il
faut arrêter de me fait votre argument
sur le recul il est
oui c'est vrai il ya moins de recul et
c'était minable nous avons des dizaines
d'années de 2 d'écart mais toutes les
études montrent que ce vaccin au fond il
est extrêmement proche du vaccin de la
grippe 1 c'est à peu près les mêmes
logiques et je vois pas vos amis en
janvier nous expliquait qu' il y avait
des jeunes qui avaient attrapé qu'on
leur inoculer la cg ouverte et tout ça
et à vos amis je veux dire un certain
nombre de jeunes qui peuvent soutenir
l'extrême droite sur les réseaux sociaux
tout ça est faux donc nous savons que
aujourd'hui la seule solution il est là
et mes excuses moi ou fait un contresens
parce que quand vous opposer le test
anti génie ou le texte pcr à la
vaccination ou fait une grossesse vous
et moi on est vacciné pour thaon
viennent de faire un test qu'on peut
parfaitement avoir une obligation
vaccinale est une obligation de test de
la même façon quand vous prenez l'avion
que vous venez chez arte ou quand vous
allez je de saison donc là il n'y a pas
deux il n'ya pas d'égal la cause
comprennent bien l'obligation vaccinale
ne veut pas dire la fin des gestes
barrières parce que nous savons que
malheureusement malgré le vaccin on peut
encore contaminé mais on ne contamine
pas de la même façon
regardez l'écart entre le nombre de gens
qui sont déclarés positifs au co vide et
la situation des hôpitaux n'est pas la
même que celle qu'elle était il ya un an
bon ok je pense que là il ya moi je fais
appel à la à l'intelligence de tous ceux
qui sont en situation de décider quel
que soit l'endroit où il le somme on
n'est pas dans une affaire idéologique
on est dans la survie de la nation
et il me semble que vous vous
obliger à des as des as des réactions
idéologique sur la liberté et ces noms
qui sont pas nécessaires alors que vous
venez de le dire vous avez propres
actions
dans le présent de finder qui dit il
faudra peut-être que les deux d'ailleurs
soit administré tous les trois quatre
mois très sincèrement est-ce que vous
voyez est brillamment d une vie oui tous
les trois-quatre mois oui
quand vous voyez comme
moi j'essaie de me savais quoi gsm
inscrire un paria rien rien vendre mois
de février passé matinée mais si demain
ça devait être le cas moi je suis
fatigué tu crois que tu es moi j'ai pas
oui j'ai pas vu est récemment je mens il
est prêté et de traiter notre
compatriote ne avec comme du bétail je
crois qu'il ya d'autres choses qu'on
peut faire j'en investi at on voit très
sûr dans les rangs être vaccinés les
5-11 ans l'a justement la bonne nouvelle
aux deux ça vous gêne pas que ça fleure
adultes en pardonnez-moi mais maggiore
est passager mais justement mais cela
nous aide énormément
depuis deux ans on a eu on a perdu il ya
vingt 20 enfants qui sont morts de -19
ans a donc enfants et adolescents un vin
c'est vous aime bien trop loin
oui c'est pas c'est pas nordique au vide
non mais c'est pas que la mort des
enfants je vais m'engager dans l'armée
vous et nordiques au bidon donc c'est
bien sûr dramatiques enfin combien
meurent du suicide quand même bien
d'autres maladies donc je voudrais juste
qu'on voit l'utiliser un peu les choses
parce que on est en train de manager par
la peur et l'inquiétude au jour mais
c'est pas en france c'est comme ça
globalement le fais je rappelle qu'il ya
mille six cent soixante quinze personnes
en réanimation aujourd'hui mission d un
soir on l'a eu à un certain moment elle
semble de pique
le vrai problème
il en parle c'est d'ailleurs parce
qu'elles vont ils parler de nombre de
personnes en réanimation c'est un
négateur n'ont pas vu parce que il sait
très bien que il est en permanence
critiquer ensuite sur la faiblesse
d'autres instruments hospitalier on a
une saturation au taux de 30 %
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas une
saturation on a aujourd'hui initiation
qui est parfaitement réglé on a juste
derrière un gros problème c'est les
soignants qui ont déserté on a un manque
de soignants deuxièmement on a un manque
de lits d'hôpitaux depuis 20 ans en mini
supprimés et en 2020 le gouvernement ait
le culot de supprimer 5700 lit en pleine
pandémie c'est absolument absolument
catastrophique et honteux ça c'est le
vrai problème est parce qu on n'a pas
aujourd'hui une capacité hospitalière
suffisante le gouvernement est en train
manager par la peur est en train de
forcer les français à se vacciner par le
passé ni terre qui ne sert plus à rien
merci et tous les deux patries
garçon de neuf ans oui la tante de
provoc s'ils ne donnent pas qu'elle sait
qui je vais pouvoir vacciner et nous qui
avons un petit garçon qui partent tous
les matins à l'école et à mon âge
puisque je suis plutôt un père âgé ben
moi je peux favoris qu'ils soient
vaccinés et captive au rugby au stade
faisait où il fonde et
des rocs et bunge aimerait aussi qui
sont vaccinés et je peux vous dire qu'il
ya beaucoup d'enfants qui souhaiterait
pour vacciner les enfants donc j'espère
j'ai eu raison
vous les
avez réfléchi
et moi je pense que c'est très important
que les hommes femmes puisque pour
vacciner eh bien merci à vous deux
patrick mennucci jean lannes avec nous
pour le test
[Rires]
et on en vient à un autre sujet un
allongement france du délai légal pour
liv et j'ai obtient le feu vert de
l'assemblée nationale un texte qui
permet d'étendre l'accès à l'avortement
à 14 semaines de grossesse au lieu des
12 jusqu'ici un texte adopté après des
débats houleux dans l'hémicycle
yamina benguigui
c'est une victoire pour les porteurs de
la loi visant à renforcer le droit à
l'avortement
l'objectif principal allonger le délai
légal pour pratiquer une interruption
volontaire de grossesse à 14 semaines au
lieu de 12 semaines actuellement c'est
pas une lubie de deux femmes militantes
féministes c'est le rencontre sur le
terrain qui a débuté il ya de nombreux
mois de nombreuses années le sujet c'est
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps laissez le sujet c'est
effectivement que certaines femmes ne
peuvent pas avorter une bataille
remportée mais une guerre loin d'être
gagnée pour les soutiens de cette
proposition de loi car elle ne fait pas
l'unanimité y compris au sein de la
majorité présidentielle
emmanuel macron lui même ayant exprimé
sa réticence se prolonger du des légions
un avis partagé par certains élus
républicains
12 10 12 semaines il suffit d'absence
d'aspirer le foetus est bien quand on
passe à quatorze semaines avec un crâne
aussi fier il y a dilatation plus
importantes du col de l'utérus à opérer
et des conséquences gynécologique qui
peuvent être graves y compris pour la
famille y compris pour de futures
grossesses avec des accouchements
malheureusement prématuré parmi les
amendements les plus âprement discutés
celui qui supprime le délai de réflexion
de 48 heures entre l'entretien
psychosocial et le recueil du
consentement à une ivg une suppression
défendu par l'aco rapporteuse
socialistes marie noëlle battistel il
n'y a pas d'atteinte à la liberté de
choix on ne supprime pas la possibilité
de réflexion pour celles qui le
souhaitent un temps de recul comme le
nomme le député les républicains
philippe gosselin qui supprime et
éloigne la loi de l'esprit de la lettre
de la loi veil -le instituant le droit à
l'avortement la clause de conscience
censé accorder la liberté au personnel
médical de refuser de pratiquer l'acte
d'h ivg a en revanche été conservé après
de multiples déboires personne est
évidemment obligé de subir un avortement
ni même d'y participer ainsi que le
dispose expressément la loi en faveur du
personnel médical et paramédical afin
que le texte soit ratifié il reste une
dernière étape celle du sénat dans le
cas où l'institution approuverait le
texte la proposition pourra être adopté
avant la fin de la session parlementaire
prévue fin février
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
brigitte letombe gynécologue
bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous en
direct
sur rt france ce projet de loi qui
comprend donc l'allongement du délai
légal dvg de douze à quatorze semaines
votre réaction progrès ou loi finalement
mal adapté
alors je voudrais déjà dire que je suis
pour le droit des femmes et que ce n'est
pas parce que je pense que c'est ta
logement n'est pas une bonne chose pour
les femmes que je suis pas pour
l'autonomie des femmes loin de là je
pratique des ivg depuis quarante ans
j'ai pratiqué à la fois la méthode
médicamenteuse et la méthode
chirurgicale ce que je peux dire c'est
que il ya certainement des choses pour
faciliter l'accès des femmes à une
possibilité d'obtenir une interruption
volontaire de grossesse en france parce
que nous avons sans doute insuffisamment
de personnel et d'accessibilité surtout
dans certaines grandes villes donc il ya
nécessité de donner plus de moyens pour
les centres d'orthogénie par contre
l'allongement du délai ne me semble pas
nécessaire il me semble plutôt délétère
pour la santé des femmes parce que cet
allongement va vraisemblablement du fait
puisqu'on n'a pas on n'a pas consulté
les professionnels
nous nous l'avons fait mais les
politiques ne l'ont pas fait et l'on
sait bien que dans les centres
d'orthogénie en fait cet allongement
risque de faire disparaître certains
praticiens faut savoir que quand on
passe
parce que c'est un geste qui est plus
difficile plus dangereux quoique l'on
dise et si on le fonction le faire par
méthode chirurgicale
et si on le fait par voie médicamenteuse
c'est quelque chose qui est évidemment
plus longue et plus douloureux pour les
femmes avec d'éventuelles séquelles
psychologiques qui pourraient exister du
fait du geste nous lourds eux donc je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse dire que ça rend
service aux femmes d'autant qu'en france
nous avons la possibilité de prendre en
charge ces femmes qui sont des dépassés
d'abord ces délais dépassés pourquoi il
y en at il en france on peut faire un
test de grossesse très rapidement et on
n'a pas besoin d'attendre quatre mois
pour se rendre compte qu'on est enceinte
c'est assez facile donc celle qui arrive
à 14 semaines sont des femmes qui soient
sans déni de grossesse dont qui ont
besoin d'un accompagnement parce que
cela veut dire qu'elles ont des
difficultés psychologiques qu'il faudra
donc les accompagner les entouraient
soit ce sont des adolescentes qui ne
connaissent pas le fonctionnement de
leur corps qui n'ont pas imaginer que un
seul rapport sexuel éventuellement dont
elle ne se souviennent peut-être pas
dans certaines circonstances et puis
mené à une grossesse et ces deux cas la
nécessite un accompagnement et cela ça
peut se faire dans le cadre de
l'interruption médicale de grossesse
psychosociale en france nous avons la
possibilité de d'interrompre des
grossesses au delà du délai légal de
l'ibg dans ce cadre là alors pourquoi
cette loi
alors je pense que c'est un lobbying
c'est une idéologie c'est peut-être
politique c'est pour donner l'impression
qu'on améliore le droit des femmes alors
que si on voulait vraiment améliorer le
droit des femmes et pour la santé des
femmes ce qu'il faut c'est permettre à
ces femmes de pouvoir quand elles ont un
désir d'interruptions de grossesse
d'avoir accès à une consultation très
rapidement et un geste rapide
aujourd'hui ce qu'il manque c'est le
nombre de centres d'orthogénie le nombre
de praticiens dans les services des
infirmières des sages-femmes des
secrétaires pour pouvoir justement faire
en sorte que ces femmes qui désirent une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
puis cette prise en charge dans les deux
à trois jours après leur demande ce qui
n'est pas le cas et je crains ce que
justement pardonnez moi docteur jouer
pardonnez moi parce que c'est important
ce que vous nous dites ça voudrait dire
peut-être que si ce délai a été allongée
c'est pour pallier justement à cette
prise en chasse très très lente
notamment dans les hôpitaux parisiens
parce que ça met du temps parce qu'on a
du mal à obtenir des rendez vous rapide
on allonge le délai de grossesse et que
dans le fond ça ne concerne pas beaucoup
de femmes qui qui arrive au bout de la
14e semaine c'est bien ce que j'ai
compris oui c'est ça et en fait ce qui
risque d'arriver c'est qu'on perdra des
professionnels qui juste là était très
investi et qui disent moi à partir du
moment où on me demande de faire ce
geste je capitule je ne veux pas le
faire donc on sait qu'il ya un certain
nombre de praticiens qui ne voudront pas
pu participer à l'activité et ça c'est
dramatique parce que c'est un risque à
ce moment d'augmenter les difficultés
d'accessibilité
docteur si vous le voulez bien vous
restez avec nous parce que liv et j'ai
c'est aussi au centre des débats
aujourd'hui aux états unis est votre
avis nous intéresse aussi on va aller à
washington où le droit à l'avortement
est aussi en question à la une
aujourd'hui avec une audience cruciale à
la cour suprême la plus haute
juridiction du pays qui se penche donc
sur un recours de l'état du mississipi
concernant une loi qui vise cette fois à
limiter l'accès ali vg on retrouve donc
à washington notre correspondant thomas
bonnet bonsoir thomas l' état du sud des
états unis qui demande donc à la cour
d'annuler sa jurisprudence qui garantit
donc le droit à l'avortement
oui et c'est déjà un événement en soi
que la cour suprême des etats unis se
penche sur cette loi du mississippi qui
a été adoptée en 2018 et qui a donc été
suspendue depuis cette loi de cet état
du sud des états unis souhaite interdire
l avortement le recours à l'avortement
après un délai de quinze semaines de
grossesse mais finalement au delà de
l'examen de cette loi par la cour
suprême est bien la plus haute
juridiction américaine pourrait vous
revoir sa jurisprudence en la matière il
ya une décision qui a été rendue par la
cour suprême en 1973 c'était il ya près
de 50 ans cette décision est communément
appelée rovi wade et c'est elle qui fixe
le droit qui garantit le droit pour les
femmes américaines de recourir à
l'avortement avec une viabilité autour
de 22 à 24 semaines alors selon les
premiers échos que l'on à des
discussions qui ont eu lieu depuis ce
matin au sein de la cour suprême des
etats unis il n'est pas à exclure que
les juges à qui forment cette cour
suprême reviennent sur cette
jurisprudence ce serait évidemment un
énorme événement aux états unis et
d'ailleurs la décision est si importante
qu'il ya à des centaines de personnes
qui se sont rassemblés depuis ce matin à
proximité de la cour suprême des
militants anti avortement et pro
avortement qui est donc ce sont en fait
face près de la cour suprême je propose
d'écouter leurs arguments respectifs
j'aime des personnes qui ont avorté je
suis vraiment là pour les soutenir je
n'ai jamais eu recours à l'avortement
mais il est possible et que j'en ai
besoin un jour il s'agit simplement de
justice en matière d'avortement et de la
libération de la porte j'espère que dans
cette affaire les juges choisiront la
vie qu'ils choisiront de maintenir la
loi du mississippi et j'espère que nous
verrons si ce n'est un renversement
complet de l'arrêt provisoire au moins
le retour d'une partie de ce pouvoir aux
états voilà pouvez constater que le
sujet de l'avortement est aussi un sujet
de fractures aux états unis un sujet
profond de division d'ailleurs si la
cour suprême des etats unis se penche
sur cette loi du mississippi et plus
généralement sur le droit à l'avortement
aux etats-unis c'est parce qu'elle est
désormais à majorité conservatrice
il ya six juges conservateurs au sein de
la cour suprême et trois juges libéraux
ne 3 avait été nommé notamment par
donald trump lors de son mandat
précédent et puis de son côté joe biden
lui a encore une fois affirmé qu'il
soutenait cette jurisprudence de la cour
suprême cette fameuse décision rovi wade
écouter le locataire de la maison
blanche fait il ya quelques instants
je n'ai rien vu du débat aujourd'hui de
la présentation aujourd'hui je soutiens
revis wade je pense que c'est la
position la plus rationnelle et je
continue à la soutenir
alors si la cour suprême venait à
changer la jurisprudence en matière
d'avortement cela voudrait dire donc que
ce serait aux états que reviendrait la
décision de fixer à des lois en matière
de droit à l'avortement certains états
pourraient donc décider de raccourcir le
délai au cours duquel les femmes ont le
droit d'avoir recours à l'avortement
vous certains pourraient aussi être
tenté d'abolir complètement l'avortement
en tout cas la décision de la cour
suprême est attendu pour le printemps
prochain ici aux etats unis
merci thomas bonnin en direct donc de
washington brigitte letombe vous êtes
toujours avec nous on le voit c'est un
enjeu important d'affaires est porté
devant la cour suprême sans doute plus
importante des décennies un qui pourrait
constituer un tournant fondamental nous
a expliqué thomas bonne et ça vous
étonne qu on remette ce droit en cause
aux états unis parfois d'ailleurs aussi
en france ah non non franchement on ne
peut pas comparer ce qui se passe aux
etats unis ce qui se passe en france en
france y'a aucun retour en arrière sur
la loi sur les visites bien au contraire
et je crois pas je crois ce qui faisait
craindre en fait c'est que cet
allongement du délai puisse réveiller
des anti ivg et donc je pense que là en
risque peut-être justement d'avoir un
retourné les pro-life parce qu'on
augmente ce délai pour l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse sinon en france
il ya vraiment aucun risque de revenir
sur la possibilité d'avoir un droit un
avortement volontaire non non je crois
qu'il ya pas à prédire je disais juste
cueillis ce voile a demandé si ça vous
étonnez qui est comme ça des
réfractaires et que le des boîtes soit
soit relevé il n'empêche docteur ne
tombe aux etats-unis le délai actuel est
bien plus élevé justement de prise en
charge pour pour liv et j'ai ce qui peut
paraître peut-être étonnant et pour le
coup peut-être vous étonnez vous puisque
vous me disais que quatorze semaines
c'était déjà trop en france en fait est
là le seul pays où on a la possibilité
de faire une interruption médicale de
grossesse sans délai c'est la france
donc ce que l'on a dans notre loi c'est
la possibilité de faire une interruption
volontaire de grossesse jusqu'à 12
semaines c'est à dire l'autonomie des
femmes il est et dès qu'il y à un
dépassement de ce délai
on peut avoir accès à une interruption
médicale de grossesse qui peut aller
mamou de là ça peut arriver que l'on
fasse d'interruption médicale de
grossesse jusqu'à 18 20 semaines et plus
longtemps pour des raisons
thérapeutiques
parce que bon quand même faire à
l'étranger dicale de gaulle 16
psychosocial dans le cadre par exemple
d'une adolescente qui ne s'est pas rendu
compte qu'elle était enceinte on la
prend en charge avec un accompagnement
psychologique dans le cadre à de déni de
grossesse si cette femme se rend compte
de sa grossesse à 18 semaines on peut
très bien la mine est envisagé une
interruption médicale de grossesse et la
compagnie non non il entend économique
et alors dépassé et de certaines femmes
aillent à l'étranger
alors elles vont à l'étranger sans doute
parce que l'utilisation de cette
interruption médicale de grossesse pour
raisons psychosocial et pas suffisamment
développée dans les centres d'orthogénie
donc cela c'est peut-être quelque chose
qu'il faudrait pas travailler davantage
mais de là à augmenter le délai pour
toutes les femmes alors que on parle
aujourd'hui d'à peu près 2000 ou 3000
femmes qui disent aller à l'étranger sur
230 mille îles et j'ai donc voyez c'est
très peu de femmes et je pense que la
bascule de l'allongement de cap jusqu'à
14 semaines de grossesse c'est-à-dire
quatre mois de grossesse risque d'être
délétère pour ce qui se passe en france
merci beaucoup en tout cas brigitte le
temps on va d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir apporté votre éclairage notre
opinion donc sur ce projet de loi
aujourd'hui concernant donc le délai de
libérer merci à vous merci à vous
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction de la
capitale suédoise où s'ouvre demain la
réunion annuelle des ministres de
l'ocelot scee pour la première fois
depuis 2017 les chefs de la diplomatie
américaine et russe sont présents
ensemble à ce rendez vous on retrouve à
stockholm notre envoyé spécial david
kelly fa bonsoir duncan qui doit donc
s'entretenir demain avec sergueï lavrov
une rencontre sur fond de tensions
autour du dossier ukrainien
a déjà ce qu'on peut dire à stéphanie
c'est qui dit conférence internationale
dit forcément embouteillages l'aéroport
de stockholm a été bloqué de pendant
près de deux heures ce qui nous a
empêchés d'atteindre l'endroit où se
déroulera la conférence est d'aider
demain dès demain matin l'hôtel en
question se trouve à une dizaine de
minutes de l'aéroport est ce qui a
provoqué un véritable branle-bas de
combat depuis depuis à peu près à 2h
alors c'est moins intensif pour le pour
le moment mais il est toujours difficile
un produit des usagers de sortir de la
zone aéroportuaire en cause l'arrivée
d'un avion d'une délégation russe alors
ce n'est pas un sergueï lavrov qui
arrivera lui est devant matin mais son
équipe de près ce qui est arrivé ce soir
est ce qui a provoqué ces l
embouteillage et la paralysie de
l'aéroport alors en tout cas vous l'avez
dire cette première journée sera marquée
par sept heures rencontre entre anthony
blinken et sergueï lavrov avec la
détention palpable autour de l'ukraine
puisque les etats-unis évoquent des
preuves montrant que la russie envisage
d' importants actes agressifs contre
l'ukraine et promet à de lui faire payer
un prix élevé si elle passe à l'acte
écoutez le chef de la diplomatie
américaine
nous sommes extrêmement préoccupée par
les preuves que la russie a prévu de
prendre d'importantes mesures agressives
contre l'ukraine ces plans comprennent
des efforts pour déstabiliser l'ukraine
de l'intérieur ainsi que des opérations
militaires à grande échelle n'est
déclarations pour le moins virulente à
savoir que toute agression de la part de
moscou aurait des conséquences profondes
et durables
washington a clairement fait savoir que
les etats-unis riposterons avec des
mesures économiques inédites en cas
d'attaqué russe alors le kremlin a de
son côté a fermement nié ces allégations
et reproche à l'otan d'attiser les
tensions dans le même temps moscou
accusé l'ukraine de rassembler des
dizaines de milliers de soldats dans
l'est du pays l inquiétude est permise
et grandir pour tous les observateurs
qui seront présents ici une cinquantaine
de deux ministres des affaires
étrangères qui sont réunis à stockholm
pour ce meeting ce 28e meeting annuel de
l'eau est en tout cas il faut trouver
une solution diplomatique à face à une
escalade dans ce conflit qui couve
depuis longtemps merci beaucoup d'avis
d'un califat en direct de stockholm
accompagné par renault parquet
et autres rencontres aujourd'hui celle
entre une délégation américaine et des
représentants talibans au qatar les deux
camps ont évoqué la crise humanitaire en
afghanistan et la réponse possible de la
communauté internationale la délégation
américaine s'est engagée à soutenir les
efforts de l'onu pour gérer la situation
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le département
d'état dans un communiqué selon le
programme alimentaire mondial des
nations unies près de 30 millions de
personnes sont menacées par la
malnutrition sévère et pour faire face à
cette catastrophe de nombreux pays ont
déjà commencé à livrer des denrées
alimentaires et du matériel pour le
peuple afghan c'est notamment le cas de
la russie et de son aviation militaire
qui multiplie les rotations à l'aéroport
de kaboul reportage de notre envoyé
spécial antoine clairon
la communauté internationale commence
doucement réagir face à la catastrophe
humanitaire qui se profile en
afghanistan lors d'une rencontre entre
américain est taliban à doha la
délégation américaine a fait savoir
qu'elle s'engager à soutenir les efforts
de l'onu pour faire face à la situation
la banque mondiale qui a suspendu ses
aides à kaboul au mois d'août dernier
envisage de nouveau à fournir de l'aide
humanitaire en afghanistan en attendant
la russie aj et vient de livrer une
deuxième cargaison d'aidé humanitaire en
moins de deux semaines
en application de la directive du
président russe le ministère de la
défense a envoyé le 1er décembre une
nouvelle cargaison daide humanitaire au
peuple afghan l'aviation militaire de
transport des forces aérospatiale russe
a transporté à kaboul 36 tonnes de
denrées alimentaires une autre cargaison
à attend son tour le volume général des
livraisons humanitaires dépassera les
100 tonnes il faut dire que la situation
sociale et économique
ici en afghanistan est très mauvaise il
ya du chômage de la famille de la misère
plus l'hiver s'approchera et pire ça
deviendra
la situation humanitaire empire de jour
en jour en afghanistan l'économie est
paralysée le système de santé est aux
abois et sans une aide massive de la
part de la communauté internationale le
pays court à la catastrophe
et pour en parler on reçoit tout de
suite régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france régis un bon soir
cette nouvelle rencontre entre
washington et les talibans avec
évidemment cet enjeu de crise
humanitaire mais dans le fond régis est
ce que les américains ont une marge de
manoeuvre est levé sur ce dossier parce
que soit on laisse mourir une population
de 2 fin soit de toute manière on perd
d'une certaine manière la face quelle
marge de manoeuvre et quels choix pour
washington
il ya plusieurs aspects dans la dans
l'attitude américaine aujourd'hui la les
états unis ont voulu commandes
immédiatement après leur leur départ
calamiteux puisque faut bien qualifier
ainsi date de l'afghanistan renouer avec
les taliban et on a vu de la part des
talibans aussi qui certaines marques je
dirais pas de sympathie mais en tout cas
vis-à-vis des etats-unis il ya eu
immédiatement à discours au moment où
ils étaient les talibans sont arrivés au
pouvoir faut pas oublier que les
talibans et les etats unis se sont
combattus pendant 20 ans et bien comme
quoi il souhaitait renouer des relations
et que les états unis alors derrière
tout ça qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se cache
il se cache une chose d'abord importante
c'est que les talibans savent qu'ils eux
pour gouverner l'afghanistan
il va falloir qu'ils aient une politique
économique et financière et pour le
moment ils ne peuvent pas le faire
puisque un certain nombre d'avoirs ça
vient d'être précisée justement par
votre reporter le on tété ont été gelés
à l'étranger donc ce qui fait que le
gouvernement taliban aujourd'hui manque
d'argent il a un certain nombre de de
contrôler une partie du pays là aussi il
ya beaucoup de difficultés de la part
des taliban à faire face notamment à des
groupes plus extrémistes comme
haïti score hassan quitte donc legmann
émanation des shs sur place qui a commis
déjà plusieurs attentats dont il reste
peu sécuritaire et surtout comme je le
disais cet aspect économique est hélas
les talibans savent qu'ils ont besoin du
reste du monde vous avez souligné l'aide
qu'apportent les russes la corée du sud
également a décidé eux de fournir de
l'aide aux commence à l'afghanistan
l'inde aussi donc il ya un certain
nombre de pays qui ont accepté cela mais
il va falloir plus de choses puisque
pour ses 20 millions d'habitants
risquent de à risque de famine avec
l'univers potentiellement très dur qu'il
qui va se dérouler en afghanistan et
vient pour éviter la catastrophe
humanitaire il va falloir autre chose
donc la communauté internationale à une
manière de faire pression sur les
talibans ont par exemple les forçant
d'une cette date ce qu'ils ont réussi
partiellement à faire les talibans ont
exprimé leur volonté de s'engager auprès
de la communauté internationale en
faveur d'un accès complet à l'éducation
notamment des femmes etc donc ça c'est
des paroles visiblement quand même suivi
d'effet et l'idée de la communauté
internationale justement c'est de
troquer un petit peu cette aide contre
eux un brevet de respectabilité de la
part des talibans et la promesse qui ne
se livre pas à des exactions loi qui ne
durcissent pas leurs régimes comme il
l'avait fait quand ils étaient au
pouvoir entre 1996 et 2001 est ce que la
communauté internationale et les états
unis en tête peuvent-ils faire confiance
aux talibans qui vont nécessairement
vouloir comme vous dites offrir voilà
une crédibilité et faire plein de bonnes
intentions mais comment obtenir des
garanties pour un avenir plus lointain
alors rien n'est certain pour pour
l'instant évidemment on ne connaît pas
et c'est là où la difficulté c'est de
savoir qui gouverne réellement au sein
des talibans qui est ce que c'est la
ligne dure incarnée par haqqani c'est à
dire les militaires ou est ce que c'est
la vie ne dirai plus
négociatrice incarné par le mollah
baradar qui était le négociateur
principal des talibans à doha pendant
toute la période avant le retour des
talibans au pouvoir donc il ya voilà il
ya des il ya plusieurs plans il ya
plusieurs il ya eu des affrontements
même entre eux mais jusqu'à présent est
la difficulté va être de savoir si les
talibans vont pouvoir se contenter
aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils font c'est à
dire à d'administrer l'afghanistan sans
faire de coup d'éclat spectaculaires
montrant des marques d'extrémisme comme
ils ont pu le faire par le passé est
hélas pour le moment on sait qu'il ya eu
des exactions mais elles n'ont pas été
massive et n'ont pas été à la situation
et reste critique le régime est bien en
place la llo l'opposition a été d'une
certaine façon contenu il n'y a plus de
manifestations de femmes comme on avait
comme on l'a vu au début mais il n'y a
pas eu d' exactions et il n'y a pas eu
enfin il ya eu des exactions mais elles
ont été limités honduras voilà parce que
les talibans savent très bien qu'ils
jouent une carte comment fragiles qu'ils
doivent contrôler le pays il ne le
contrôle pas complètement gelé déjà dit
est également il en commet un problème
de montrer au reste du monde qu'ils
peuvent administrer et qu'ils sont des
interlocuteurs légitimes
ça c'est une chose est de ce point de
vue là ils se tiennent jusqu'à présent
et voilà et mais tout ça est ce que dans
le dans le dans le fond les talibans
l'intention de poursuivre dans cette
voie là toute la question n'est toujours
pas soldé ou est-ce que l'afghanistan va
redevenir un état paria comme il l'avait
été lors du précèdent la précédente
présence d'état des talibans au pouvoir
en afghanistan
merci beaucoup résident ça le sommier
merci pour votre éclairage ce soir resté
avec moi dans quelques instants
auparavant de la lutte pour l'égalité
des genres évoquée par certains
candidats à la poche de la
présidentielle
bree qu'en pensent les français nous
irons à la rencontre de la première mère
transgenre de france elle souhaite se
lancer dans la course à l'elysée est
temps aujourd'hui de réunir ses 500
parrainages
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur imdb c'est une réalité et hopitalisé
il était nulle part est ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous petit
coup politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent là l on soit vient de
l'ignorance aujourd'hui on a une gauche
c'est extrêmement intéressant
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage des ritable se situe au niveau
des hommes politiques plus de 3000
ivoiriens en perdront la vie lors de la
crise post électorale de 2010 2011 avait
beaucoup de tension ça tire de partout
c'était des formats l'as cozes et anton
soit et envoyait des tasses des balles
par ci par là on voyait des cadavres en
moins d'une semaine c'était c'était le
chaos après 2010 il y avait deux camps
celui des vainqueurs et des vaincus
est-ce que la situation s'est quand même
amélioré à ce niveau le châtel que la
victime se plaignent tous jouent le fait
est que sur le terrain la division
existe ou jouent le jeu fait est que le
climat politique n'est pas encore
véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si
maureen dowd et qu'une catastrophe est
tout à fait déplorable on a vu des
personnes gravement blessées on a
entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 nomel pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine billes dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qu'était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la lutte pour l'égalité des
dents au centre des débats à la proche
de la présidentielle jean-luc mélenchon
on a faim et l'un de ses chevaux de
bataille de candidats de la france
insoumise veut même l'inscrire dans la
constitution ce droit de changer de
genre mais va-t-il trop loin certains en
tout cas le pense dans notre rubrique en
pensent les français ce soir nous irons
à la rencontre de mariko première mère
transgenres du pays et nous livrera son
témoignage
[Musique]
la question du genre qui s'invite donc
dans le débat présidentiel il y a
quelques jours où jean luc mélenchon en
a fait l'art de l'une de ses priorités
le candidat de la france insoumise veut
inscrire dans la constitution le droit
de choisir son genre mais va-t-il trop
loin dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent
les français nous allons ce soir la
rencontre de marie commères transgenres
elle dénonce chez les politiques des
postures trop simpliste sur ces
questions elle a du coup décidé d'être
candidate à la présidentielle un
reportage signé renaud parquet et
guyomard aussi
je me trouve actuellement à tilloy lez
marchiennes dans le nord cette commune
qui a défrayé la chronique l'an dernier
c'est ici qui a été élu pour la toute
première fois en france une mère
transgenres elle s'appelle mariko et
elle a accepté de nous recevoir
suivez-moi
maiko bonjour merci de nous recevoir
j'avais une première question en
préambule de nombreuses femmes féminisé
des noms de fonction du coût est ce que
je dois vous appeler madame le maire ou
madame la maire mouassa pas d'importance
je pense que ce qui est plus important
c'est la fonction est ce que vous vous
attendiez à devenir un symbole même à un
symbole malgré vous je m'attendais juste
un petit buzz locale c'est clair que ça
fait pas mal de buzz ma grande surprise
on a récupéré une commune qui était ou
qui avait plus beaucoup d'argent en
caisse donc il a fallu aussi remettre en
place toute la partie administration et
après on a lancé les projets de la fibre
optique qui était une attente importante
dans le village la rénovation de
l'ancienne mairie qui va devenir une
salle communale pour accueillir les
associations et toutes les activités
périscolaire vous êtes ingénieur mais
femme est ce que vous avez dû prouver
vos compétences vis-à-vis de nous de vos
administrés et même avant votre élection
alors tout début il ya d'abord fallu que
je rassure tout comme chez des personnes
transgenres disais qu'est ce qui va se
passer que son jugement rendu compte que
j'étais une personne comme les autres
d'après la difficulté c'est plus quand
on est femme forcément connais rien à la
technique gens qui disent mais je peux
pas vous expliquer vous comprendrez par
magie elle si tu peux m'expliquer vous
pouvez m'expliquer je vais comprendre
n'y a pas de souci donc on a toujours
cette condescendance de certaines
personnes par rapport au fait d'être
femme
et quelle est la perception selon vous
du débat sur le genre en france sur
cette question au niveau national
malheureusement c'est un des réflexions
qui aurait dû rester du niveau du
sociétal de l'étude sociologique et
c'est devenu un sujet politique alors le
genre il ya eu des études sur le genre
lancée par les mouvements féministes
dans les années soixante dix qui étaient
des réflexions sur la construction
sociale du genre ce que simone de
beauvoir disait on n'est pas femme on le
devient c'est une problématique plus tôt
de construction culturelle et sociale il
était resté un petit peu dans la sphère
du féminisme avec la visibilité des
personnes trans gens ce débat là est
revenu mais il a été un petit peu
galvaudé perverti et c'est devenu un
fantasme d'extrême droite qui voit chez
pearson tranchant où tout ce qui tourne
autour du jean comme une attaque contre
la sexualité la famille traditionnelle
et c'est ce qu'il faut y'a pas ce qu'il
y'a pas de turiddu gens ça n'existe pas
il ya eu des études sur le genre n'ya
pas théorie du genre donc c'est devenu
très politique c'est devenu un chiffon
rouge entre l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche qui au final desservent
les personnes lgbt puisqu'aujourd'hui on
se retrouve au milieu d'une arène
médiatique qui nous dessert plutôt
qu'elle ne sert qu est ce que vous
pensez par exemple de la proposition de
jean luc mélenchon de changer la
constitution pour y inclure quelque
chose sur la liberté des gens oui je
pense que c'est très démagogique parce
que depuis absolument pas besoin de
changer la constitution pour faire ça
c'est juste le pragmatique de code civil
on tue suffit de rajouter trois lignes
dans le code civil et pis c'est bon donc
là on est on là on est clairement dans
de la démagogie c'est clair aujourd'hui
il ya des familles monoparentales on a
le rôle du beau parent on a des premiers
sur l'adoption l'accouchement sous x
filiation l'épreuve de filiation pma gp
à ckoi parents biologiques
aujourd'hui le code civil est ancien il
hérité d'une culture latine et pineapp
au tapis surtout napoléon donc c'est ça
nécessite une remise en question donc
avait une vision très patriarcales des
choses aujourd'hui ça a changé faut pas
être dans le déni faut légiférer
intelligemment sur ces sujets là plutôt
que laisser les extrémismes sans parler
de ces sujets justement je vous ai
entendu critiquer par ailleurs le
mouvement rock ou disons que ça faisait
beaucoup de dégâts parce que c'était pas
assez qu'on prie qu'est ce que vous
vouliez dire ce que vous pouvez
développer le mouvement voit qu'à
l'origine cette part d'un idéal
d'ouverture des consciences du respect
de l'autre c'est très bien mais comme
souvent les idéaux sont perverties
deviennent des idéologies voir après des
sectes et là c'est effectivement ce
qu'on assiste avec le mouvement walkie
un peu été dénaturé devenu le secteur et
qui aujourd'hui ne correspond pas du
tout à la vision universaliste de la
république française et des oppresseurs
des oppressés manichéen c'est simpliste
au final ça n'amène pas la compréhension
ça n'amène pas la tolérance ça n'amène
que le rocher et des postures de
agressive à vous êtes candidate à
l'élection présidentielle vous êtes en
train de réunir vos 500 signatures
quelle candidate serait vous est ce que
vous serez un porte étendard ou alors
qu'est ce que vous portez un projet plus
large c'est pas une candidature de
témoignage ni étendard je suis pas là
pour défendre un lobby une association
un mouvement politique on peut faire des
choses simples pour améliorer la
situation sans vouloir casser le système
s'en remettre en place des seizièmes
république ou révolutionner les choses
je pense avec beaucoup de bienveillance
et des couteaux on peut améliorer les
choses assez facilement donc là c'est
plutôt une candidature citoyenne hors
parti parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
n'ont plus confiance dans les partis et
donc il faut se réunir sont nos valeurs
et arrêter de se diviser
entre gauche droite sinon l'offre
politique va continuer à s'appauvrir et
on aura un non choix et annonce soit les
gens apprennent à s'exprimer dans
l'abstention dans l'extrémisme ou dans
les révoltes de rue alors faut-il
inscrire le droit de choisir son genre
dans la constitution comme le proposons
luc mélenchon vraiment nécessaire de le
graver dans le marbre pour être acceptée
ou mesure inutile on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france et place au face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler anthony
gratacos secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct avec
nous également gens mais s'il ya un
président d'un institut apollon bonsoir
jean médias merci de nous accompagner
par skype également pour ce face à face
alors pour commencer une réaction à ce
reportage que vous venez de voir mariko
qui dénonce que le genre soit devenu une
question politique ce sont des
réflexions qui aurait dû rester sociétal
seins dit-elle vous partagez cette
opinion en touche finalement alain team
anthony gratacos oui tout à fait c'est
une question qui concerne chacun dans
son dans son for intérieur dans sa vie
de tous les jours et autant l'état doit
garantir l'égalité pour chacun autant il
n'a pas à se mêler de ce qui se passe
dans la vie privée des uns et des autres
quand on dit l'état de doit garantir ça
veut dire quoi on doit le garantir
jusqu'à dans la constitution alors non
pour paraphraser montesquieu est parfois
nécessaire de modifier la constitution
mais lorsque cela est fait il faut le
faire d'une main tremblante la
constitution c'est un texte très
important c'est la loi fondamentale de
la république qui organise nos
institutions et qui est dit les
principes fondamentaux et je ne crois
pas que les revendications sociétales et
sa place est d'ailleurs
inscrire une telle revendication est
légitime et qui existe d'ailleurs dans
la loi c'est déjà possible de le faire
dans la constitution ça on changerait
profondément la nature la constitution
aujourd'hui c'est un texte qui parle de
nos droits collectifs et pas de droits
individuels et ce droit individuel il
est plus forte dans les pays anglo
saxons par les communautarismes c'est
tout à fait contraire à nos principes
on va en parler justement c'est
communautariste jean messia on doit
pouvoir choisir son genre où il nous est
attribué il a demandé la naissance quel
est votre avis
mais je pense que la liberté de changer
de sexe elle existe déjà
la liberté de changer de genre sans
changer de sexe pour moi est
inconsolable
avec cette folie on se retrouve en effet
avec des individus qui ont des attributs
masculins par exemple dans des équipes
sportives de filles le femme ou qui vont
dans les vestiaires féminins de clubs de
sport qui vont aller dans les toilettes
pour femmes j'en passe et des meilleurs
je pense qu'il s'agit là d'un délire
transgenres risque avec lequel il faut
absolument arrêter un homme a le droit
d'aimer à manom
incontestable et même de l'épousé est
symétriquement pour les femmes mais on
peut pas céder aux desiderata d'ultra
minorité qui ne réclame pas des droits
mais des privilèges exorbitants du droit
commun donc en réalité pour dire hausse
clairement out un bon spectateurs
téléspectateurs c'est que
vous avez un pénis n'a été constatée
dans notre essence vous êtes un homme
vous avez un utérus a été constaté à
votre et bien vous êtes une femme si
vous vous faites opéré qu'un chirurgien
atteste que vous avez changé de sexe
alors bien sûr vous pouvez changer
d'état civil mais sinon vous restez ce
que vous êtes au moins pour la société
ce que vous sentez dans votre tête c'est
votre affaire personnelle je crois que
on ne peut pas faire la société peuvent
pas s'adapter aux délires individuelles
des uns et des autres je pense que là où
c'est vraiment assez pernicieuse et que
on parle beaucoup de l'écologie à juste
titre les écologistes ont pris je dirais
part au débat public de manière très
importante et c'est un essai très très
bien mais la première des écologique
écologie humaine c'est à dire que pas si
vous voulez défendre les droits naturels
d'aider de toutes les espèces à 1 x
animale et des espèces d'insectes et
venir nier par une projection de la
pensée humaine ce qu'est la nature
humaine la nature humaine a fait que
l'une et ses hommes ou femmes mais qu'
on a comparé des gens mais si on va vous
évidemment vous redonner la parole mais
on va justement écouter quand même jean
luc mélenchon puisque c'est lui qui a
vraiment mis ce débat sur la table
c'était le 17 novembre m'écoutais je
dis juste que si c'est votre intime
conviction que vous êtes une femme ou un
homme vous avez le droit de l'affirmer
contre la réalité des apparences de
votre corps la société la seule chose
qu'elle peut espérer c'est que vous
soyez bien dans votre peau dans votre
rôle dans votre genre celui que vous
aurez décidé anthony gratacos comme le
dit jean messias est une forme de délire
ou comme le dit jean luc mélenchon il
faut que finalement la société aide les
individus être bien dans leur peau et
leur garantissent justement ce droit
mais ni l'un ni l'autre
toit c'est un droit qui est déjà inscrit
dans la loi et à partir du moment où ça
ne pose pas de problème à la société
dans son ensemble je ne vois pas de
problème à ce que quelqu'un change de
genre et les procédures qui sont faites
aujourd'hui qui peuvent être lourdes
parce que sont des sujets qu'il faut
prendre quand même avec beaucoup de
précaution derrière il ya beaucoup de
souffrance et jean luc mélenchon l'a dit
dans son intervention d'ailleurs et il
avait raison pour autant c'est une
décision qui est lourde de conséquences
et qui ne peut pas être prise à la
légère mais ça quand il dit c'est une
forme de délire non mais après je pense
que c'est symptomatique
c'est symptomatique d'une dérive
identitaire de la société dans son
ensemble qui correspond pas au projet
républicain français qui se tournent de
plus en plus vers l'exaltation de
l'individu contre le projet collectif et
l'individu en tant que tel c'est un peu
la nouvelle donne et qui emplit le
siècle comme aurait dit malraux et ses
communautés ces groupes d'individus qui
se rassemblent où se reconnaissent via
leur religion parce que là c'est la
question du genre mais en fait ça touche
tout un tas de sujets via leur couleur
de peau leur religion leur pratique
sexuelle ou leur genre sont des délits
ch de consommateurs formidable pour le
capital c'est plus un problème
capitaliste qui nous a été importé du
monde anglo saxon via les réseaux
sociaux qu'un problème revendicatif en
soi parce que ça concerne très peu de
gens en réalité et c'est pour ça que ça
n'a pas sa place dans la constitution
qui est une règle générale mais par
contre ça à sa place dans le droit civil
et ça y est déjà jean mais ça c'est vrai
que mariko c'est ce qu'elle dit alors
que c'est la première mère 30 secondes
candidat à la présidentielle réponse le
mode de walk it mais elle a des mots
assez durs
d'ailleurs alors on pourrait s'attendre
à ce qu'elles défendent justement cette
culture web comme on dit et là il ya une
forme de perversion en substance dit
elle
alors je suis d'accord avec ce que c'est
que ce qu'elle dit je suis également
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire votre
intervenants c'est vrai que la première
des identités dans un projet républicain
et l'identité nationale le projet
républicain est un projet qui reconnaît
des citoyens ne reconnaît pas des
individus suis style membres d'une
minorité ou en tout cas autoproclamé
donc évidemment que si vous retirez la
citoyenneté si vous retirez les
quantités vous créez un espèce de désert
et la nature ayant horreur du vide sur
ses déserts vont pousser des ronces
parfois monstrueuse de particularisme
d'individualités qui vont essayer de de
ce grand créé en quelque sorte des
ersatz
d'identité qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
sexuelle
identités de gens désirant de vie
religieuse désir de 9 10 ans d identité
pardon culinaires et que sais-je encore
quant à jean luc mélenchon
je pense que alors même que lui se
prétend républicain il est dans un tel
déficit des lecteurs il va racler
finalement tous les fonds de tiroirs
diversiterre donnez lui un peu de temps
à jean luc mélenchon il demandera
avortement jusqu'à six mois pour les
faits ministre ultra le droit de vote
pour les ca et des chats avant afin de
plaire aux animalistes l'appel à la
prière des médecines diffusé par haut
parleur bon mobile pour complaire aux
musulmans etc etc donc je pense que j'en
ris avec jean message aux variations
messia c'est une caricature je comprends
le sens de la de la proposition de jean
luc mélenchon il souhaite sanctuariser
cette disposition
parce qu'il peut qu ils considèrent
qu'elle pourrait être en danger
aujourd'hui vu les débats qui traversent
notre société
mais je pense qu'il est passé à côté des
conséquences que cela aurait sur la la
la la
constitution elle-même sur la façon dont
elle est composée le changement de
nature que ça entraînerait de là à dire
que dans six mois il proposera le vote
des chiens et des chats ou de je ne fais
quoi il ya quand même un monde entre les
deux en tout cas ce débat et mais pas
que on agite même les instances
européennes la commissaire à l'égalité a
récemment distribué un guide interne
avec la liste de certains termes
proscrit petit aperçu du nouveau manuel
de savoir vivre au sein de l'union
européenne qui a pour l'instant pas été
entérinés parce que ça a ému jusqu'au
vatican écoutez
un autre communication ne doit jamais
présumer que les personnes sont
hétérosexuels s'identifie avec le genre
attribué à leur naissance ou s'identifie
de manière binaire écarté aussi
l'utilisation de monsieur ou madame anne
basée uniquement sur le sexe a signé à
la naissance en cas de doute utilisé mx
n'ont jamais sien on imagine que tout ça
ça vous fait bondir ce guide qui
d'ailleurs ne remporte pas que les
questions du jeu mais aussi de la
chrétienneté noël et marie serait
proscrit selon la commissaire à
l'égalité elle aimerait qu'on parle de
la période des
vacances de fin d'année au lieu de
parler de la période de noël en c'est ça
qui a émis le vatican et c'est ce qui
bloque pour le moment ce guide interne
ça vous fait bondir on mélange tout
selon vous
écoutez moi je pense que l'union
européenne depuis le début en tout cas
dans le tour lent des années 90 et 2000
agit contre les nations et contre les
identités nationales dont l'union
européenne va promouvoir toutes les
identités alternative qu'elle soit
religieuse sexuelle culinaires et cetera
pour s'en servir comme bélier pour
défoncer en quelque sorte les reliquats
d'identité nationale parce que l'union
européenne s'imaginent que les suns
obstacle à l'émergence d'une identité
européenne qui serait qu'une identité
économique d'une certaine façon et est
bien c'est de mettre à mal les identités
nationales or je suis désolé je pense
que c'est pas ainsi qu'on va amener les
citoyens
des nations européennes à se sentir
européen je constate d'ailleurs que en
même temps qu'elle nie l'existence de
noël l'existence de ces deux 2 de marie
est ce que vous venez de dire elle
affirme également d'autres identités
puisque l'union européenne le demande
par exemple de prendre en ligne de
compte l'émergence de minorités
musulmanes de minorités religieuses etc
donc moi j'étais pour ceux qui
militaient pour l'inscription des
traditions judéo chrétiennes dans la
constitution européenne il est évident
que c'est pas en étant une union
hors-sol déracinés en quelque sorte que
l'union européenne va susciter
l'adhésion des citoyens puisque pour
être citoyen eh bien on est enracinée
dans une nation dans une culture dans
des traditions et si l'union européenne
veut effectivement suscité l'adhésion
des citoyens à l'idée européenne
eh bien elle ferait mieux de cultiver ce
que nous sommes plutôt que de cultiver
ceux qui sont contre nous légèreté de
façon à tenir à cause justement sur ce
guide interne encore une fois qui n'a
pas été validé mais enfin c'est vrai ne
pas utiliser mesdames et messieurs de
manière à ne pas vexer les personnes
intersexe ou cuir c'est ce qu'elle 17
comités cette commissaire à l'egalité
noël et marie on en parle de plus non
plus noël le mot et est banni est ce que
ça vous choque est ce que c'est pas un
peu contre productif on parlait
justement à l'époque je crois que c'est
nadine morano qui voulait mettre dans la
constitution justement les racines
chrétiennes
est ce que justement c'est le même pied
d'égalité où c'est différent pour vous
ces deux aspects pourtant qui sont
mélangés dans ce guide interne européen
bon c'est un document de travail fdt
annaba encore valeur réglementaire mais
je ne suis pas non plus sur la position
de jean messia les valeurs chrétiennes
etc en des débats traverse notre société
aujourd'hui on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord en tout cas il va falloir en
parler parce que beaucoup de jeunes sont
attachées par exemple à ces débats la
question qui se pose à nous en ce qui
concerne l'europe c'est qu'on a vu par
exemple il ya quelques semaines une
vidéo qui mettait en valeur le port du
voile ça fait ça fait polémique on voit
que le commissaire à l'egalité
voit que l'union européenne la
commission le parlement etc sont
infiltrés aujourd'hui le terme et
est assez juste il n'est pas trop fort
par des lobbys qui sont puissants qui
ont des moyens très importants et qui
essayent de pousser dans un sens ou dans
un autre et la réalité c'est que ceux
qui défendent aujourd'hui les valeurs
universelles les valeurs républicaines
ceux qui cherchent à défendre un projet
européen d'émancipation des peuples eux
ne mettent pas les mêmes moyens ne sont
pas aussi nombreux et ne font pas autant
de lobbying et il va falloir que le
l'ailé gauche européenne au lieu de se
perdre dans des combats minoritaires et
identitaire comprennent qu'aujourd'hui
on est en danger sur ces questions et
qu'on est attaqué de toutes parts à la
fois par les islamistes à la fois par
les identitaires d'extrême droite et
qu'il va falloir qu'on se réveille pour
imposer notre point de vue merci
beaucoup en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous mais d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir et avant de se quitter
je voudrais vous rappeler notre adresse
internet pour nous envoyer vos
témoignages
qu'en pensent les français s'affichent
sur votre écran occupé à l'aide point fr
on
s'intéresse désormais à présent à la
réforme controversée de
l'assurance-chômage nouvelle étape
franchie aujourd'hui avec l'entrée en
vigueur de son dernier volet ils eurent
c'est l'accès à l'indemnisation il faut
désormais avoir travaillé six mois et
non 4 sur les deux dernières années pour
bénéficier d'une allocution allocations
chômage les explications en images
[Musique]
pour
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
françois foucart art secrétaire national
cftc gc en charge et des parcours
professionnels de l'emploi et de la
formation bonsoir monsieur foccart merci
d'être avec nous c'est donc une nouvelle
étape aujourd'hui on imagine de la
déception voire de la colère chez vous
la déception c'est sûr de la colère
depuis le départ puisque on s'est battu
depuis le projet de loi sur ce sujet
pour la cfe cgc clairement le
gouvernement veut mettre la pression sur
les faibles ceux qui ont des difficultés
pour retrouver un emploi et aussi avec
une approche adéquat sioniste on a vu le
gouvernement n'arrête pas de dire qu'il
ya un million d'emplois qui sont pas
pourvus et en fait il veut que ça match
mais on sait très bien que les parcours
professionnels c'est pas ça aujourd'hui
clairement on
rend la vie extrêmement compliquée aux
chômeurs ça change beaucoup cette
réforme
bac pour les plus précaires le passage
de 4 à 6 mois va faire que ça sera
beaucoup plus dur pour eux d'être
indemnisés et les gens qui ont fait
cette réforme ont oublié que c'était
aussi pour réduire la partie comme ils
s'appellent entre guillemets travail au
noir pour légaliser des choses là
abandonné il ya beaucoup de gens qui
devront éventuellement pu intérêt à
cotiser est repassé dans un niveau du
travail au noir et sur la partie
dégressivité en fait on voit que pour
les cadences et des gens qui ont des
difficultés à retrouver un emploi parce
qu'il suffit pas juste de travail
traverser la rue quand on a perdu un
emploi d'un certain niveau justement ça
va augmenter encore davantage la
précarité des des plus créé peu précaire
ah c'est sûr toute façon le gouvernement
ça va être des vases communicants on
devrait le retrouver sur le rsa
a abandonné les personnes qu'ils vont
pas été indemnisées vont se retrouver
soi sur les minimas sociaux soit sur la
ss mais devra se passer des choses pour
les plus de cinquante trois ans ce sont
les trois dernières années qui seront
pris en compte
là aussi coup dur ça va changer les
choses
ah bah forcément ça va forcément ça va
changer des choses puisque en perdant 30
% des rémunérations
enfin des indemnités si vous avez encore
des charges que ce soit vos enfants qui
sont dans des écoles ou pour payer votre
est un moment donné il va se passer des
choses c'est clair aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que alizés les personnes veulent
travailler ce qu'on oublie toujours
c'est que 50% des gens qui sont
indemnisés travail chaque mois
dernière question jean-françois faux car
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire
familièrement s'est pliée plus de marge
de manoeuvre de la part des des
syndicats
à l'heure actuelle c'est entre
guillemets c'est plié on attend le
résultat du conseil du conseil d'état
mais vu le réquisitoire le dernier
réquisitoire on pense que de toute façon
ça ça va continuer son bonhomme de
chemin après la seule chose qu'on peut
espérer c'est que il va y avoir de
nouveau une négociation pour que une
nouvelle convention démarre au 1er
novembre 2022
je pense qu'il faudra attendre le
nouveau gouvernement donc ça devrait pas
être à sa place devrait être plutôt en
2023 en début 2023 mais on essaiera de
récupérer ces choses à mais on verra
bien dans quel état et les volontés du
nouveau gouvernement avec la lettre de
cadrage qu'il nous donnera merci
beaucoup jean-françois foccart remercier
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent demain 20h
pour un nouveau numéro d' attendant
l'actualité continue sur rt france
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure du genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des singes on a l'impression
qu'on descend des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés et nous sommes
cousins la grand mère maternelle qui
était bretonne me disais si toi tu
descendu sa joie sûrement pas révélé
nous un secret vous en avez mangé du
manu je me trouvera à fouiller en
sibérie et puis un beau matin dans le
trou que j'avais commencé à creuser je
trouve de lait tout comme ce quelque
chose de billard des grands filaments je
suis étonnée je râle je dirais que ce
sont des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos pour vous
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle